these elephants are being targeted
the breeding females are tracked down
then shot but not with a bullet with a
vaccine I think for me the biggest thing
is that it's a proactive
humane way of controlling elephant
populations JJ finaltona is part of a
team from Humane Society International
Africa administering immuno
contraception it's an approach often
used by private reserves in this part of
South Africa to stop the elephants from
breeding the vaccine causes the immune
system to produce antibodies that
prevent fertilization it's absolutely
not what we would use as humans for
contraception because it's non-hormonal
and it's non-steroidal and so this is
the beauty of this methodology it
actually works on the animal's own
immunity the program has been a success
with almost 1400 females treated since
it was launched more than two decades
ago when we started everybody was like
immuno contraception wow that's very
controversial you'll never get it to
work to where in 2008 it was included in
our national norms and standards while
the number of elephants is plummeting
across the continent populations in
southern Africa are expanding I think
the perception is out there is that
elephants are endangered and that they
you know we're going to lose them
they're going to go extinct it's
definitely not the case salati game
reserve general manager Brian harverman
says all parks are required by law to
have an elephant management plan I think
we've had a really good conservation
practices in South Africa and as a
result we've been able to increase their
population and we actually don't know
where to put our elephants and it's not
just private reserves that have to
navigate this problem elephants can
consume up to 400 kilograms of
vegetation in a day
while foraging they routinely destroy
crops and farm infrastructure
threatening the livelihoods of entire
communities we're struggling with
elephants timing again now we're crying
because the elephants are damaging their
crops but you never know in the near
future what kind of incident are we
gonna get
Thompson engamani grows melons peanuts
and Maize in a small Village North of
Kruger National Park
when the elephants come in here they
damage everything they eat almost
everything mainly the peanuts they
uproot them and leave them everywhere on
the ground
conservationists say it's important to
find sustainable ways to mitigate
conflict between wild animals and people
the damage to crops can be substantial
because a lot of people living around
these protected areas are impoverished
and that's their food source so you've
got the lemongrass yeah one solution
according to Michelle Henley who's been
studying elephants for 25 years is
growing aromatic herbs such as chili or
lemongrass so if you plant those crops
in a broad barrier around your your
palatable crops that you want to use as
a food source that's another way to
deter elephants and to get income
another is installing hives these giant
animals are scared of bees the hives
have the Dual benefit of protecting
Farmers as well as the trees elephants
destroy while searching for food the
debate will continue about how best to
manage the growing numbers of these
beautiful elephants what isn't in
dispute though is protecting these
animals and preserving biodiversity in
the area
Emily anguin Al Jazeera Kruger National
Park South Africa